ah
hope everyone's doing well tonight
ah
dang thing forgot to mute that all right
there we go
hi there connor you're not gonna believe
this but a bat flew into my half
brother's room last night how it got
there
i don't know i do believe it i've had a
bat in my house before
they are really hard to get out so are
birds when i was in new york i had a
bird fly into
my apartment so uh yeah
small flying things are not easy to deal
with
how you been i've been i've been pretty
good
um i had a um at a very relaxed weekend
which was nice and and very welcome
looking good oh thank you ms wicked wolf
so um i'm probably going to be jumping
or well
what will probably happen is what
usually happens um
in these things which is that ultimately
the um the discussion will be
driven by you folks in your questions
more than anything else
uh have you watched dark on netflix it's
good but so complicated
it makes river's timeline look like one
plus one i haven't watched dark
um but to whatever degree
that i i am allowed to default
uh sort of the things i figure i'll
touch on this time are
any lingering thoughts uh from disney
fandom
mulan which is coming out soon and i've
got my kickstarter
launching in two weeks uh today's tim
burton's 62nd br
60 second wow favorite tim burton movie
um
i want to say big fish but i also
haven't rewatched it recently enough to
have a lot of confidence in that
love those nails my nails are are
cavalcade of nonsense today is
what's going on like this hand is almost
normalized this one is just
the insanity but thank you
love the coat you wore in your dr
speeches countdown by the way thank you
so much i love that
i love that outfit i'm i'm
i'm looking for excuses to wear that
outfit again
i i had a lot of fun with that
i'm excited to see suicide squad because
of peter capaldi
that's good but like be careful given
the size of this cast
definitely they're going to kill a fair
number of them and it's quite possible
that some of them are going to die early
on so like don't ping your entire hopes
for that movie on
any one actor aside from like the
returning ones they'll still be around
uh looks like the 12th doctor finally
has stephen moffat's massive
massive brain
props just too bagful for that thing
that should have been a meme
might i ask what the kickstarter is
specifically for not only can you ask
i can point you to a link down in the
description of this very video which
will take you to the pre-release page
sorry pre-launch page for the
kickstarter it is to
fund my fantasy novel um more specific
most specifically to
fund um illustration i'm going to tilt
this
a little bit sorry it was bugging me a
little i was off center
um so the main thing that it will be
funding in regards to the book
is um illustrations for it because i
don't
know exactly why the idea of it being an
illustrated novel stuck in my head but
it did and it won't go away
and i can't afford i i can't draw
and i can't afford to fund those myself
so that's the main thing that the
kickstarter will be funding in addition
to things like
professional book cover being able to
print
advanced reader copy so i can get it out
there and get it in the hands of people
who are going to review it
um get a world map made you know
professionally and then things like that
what are your thoughts on spaceballs
that was that i don't know if that was
the first mel brooks movie
i saw it was definitely the first one
that i remember
so i will always have a soft spot for
that one
ed wood is number one for me my all-time
favorite biopic
i like ed wood i think ed wood was over
hyped
for me um before i got to see it even if
you haven't watched it i should mention
that the season finale of the owl house
is this saturday i may need a
defibrillator after because i'm so
excited i actually really want to see
owl house
the problem is i don't have
disney channels just coming into my
house i have
disney plus but it's not going to go on
there until it's done airing its season
so hopefully in a week or two i'll be
able to start watching it but in the
meantime i'm just watching other people
go crazy for it
so that's that's annoying me a little
today is also sean connery's 90th
birthday oh
that's wonderful he can hit a woman in
celebration
that i'm sorry that was that was
unnecessarily salty um
i i may need to hydrate sorry
my nails are a cavalcade of nonsense you
say that like it's a bad thing
no i say it like uh it's up to you as to
whether or not that's a good thing
some people ask what buffy did right was
it the female empowerment the sexy
vampires no
it was dawning it was dawn and conor in
the little
s asterisk asterisk t department uh
that's a interesting take
will hamilton be your next obsession i
mean to the degree that i get obsessed
with
um with musicals i am listening to it a
lot
um so i i am enjoying it you know
figuring out which songs are
are in my range and figure out what ones
i will actually get all the lyrics down
to
it's not many yet thank you amanda
again no question but love and gratitude
from over the pond in
scotland thank you so much what's your
opinion
on ea
look let me put it this way for all the
stuff going on in gaming
right now i'm really glad that i
naturally phased out
of current gen gaming years ago
about a decade ago now and
it's companies like ea and activision
and most of them
actually but ea is a really prime
example of
many of the reasons why i'm glad i don't
game anymore
since we're talking novels the tobias
agency are getting a lot of hate for
doing the right
thing i'm not entirely sure what that's
in reference to so you may have to
clarify that for me
i'm actually super excited for the
batman i'm hopeful
i i want to see a trailer after they've
shot more of it because i feel like
what they were able to present was
somewhat limited by how little of the
movie had been shot
so i'm a little bit curious what they'll
market it as once we have
once they have a more complete round of
filming
me do you watch 101 down nation street
michelle gomez plays cruella to phil
i i'm
i i don't even know what that is but i'm
immediately curious
uh i saw mars attacks very hungover on
first release should i rewatch it
um honestly
no it's not worth seeing more than once
even if you were drunk or hungover
oh perhaps you'd have thought before the
sean connery joke
whatever what's your favorite movie or
tv show
set or made in your home state
um huh
i mean for set here i really liked uh
state and maine
uh which was a david mamet movie or at
least he wrote the script i don't know
if he directed it to
for actually filmed in vermont there
aren't many
at least not that filmed the bulk of
their stuff here there's a handful of
things that like filmed
a little bit here and it's not many
though
bit of an odd question how much did
eccleston's autograph cost
if i remember correctly this is me going
off memory from
six months ago so don't quote me on this
i think it was 60 bucks
i don't know i won't swear to that in
court
what are your thoughts on the uh deep
faking dead doctors for new episodes
specials rather than using different
actors i
okay so
let me put my foot down about this as
far as my personal position and this is
my personal position
i'm not saying anyone else who believes
differently is wrong
i am however gonna be very firm on this
i do not think
that they should be
either recasting or deep faking
deceased doctors or doctors who have
visibly aged
too much um
i gave a semi pass to
um oh god i've i've lost his name now
but the guy who played the first doctor
um in twice upon a time
i gave a semi-pass to that one because
he had played
hardnell in an adventure in time and
space and so there was that connection
and like i'm totally fine with him
playing
you know william hartnell in a biopic so
like that was totally fine
and so because of that i like i let that
one slide
david bradley thank you i know it was
david something
but i am really not okay
with them doing either one as a regular
thing
i was okay with things like the closing
shot of the day of the doctor which is
just a lineup
that's fine but i for one
am not comfortable with either one if
you're gonna force me to choose
i would rather they recast
than um do some version of deep faking
i don't want them to do either because i
want the era and the time of those
doctors to be defined by the actors who
played them in the instant you start
recasting
or start having it being played by you
know
with technology to create a look-alike
or whatever
you are bringing up the possibility that
eventually this doctor will not be
defined by the
by the actor who created them and that's
how it's been with the doctors for this
long
and i don't get this way necessarily
about most characters
but something about this one the idea of
doing either one just
feels very wrong to me and i'm not
comfortable with it
do you dance um depends on my mood
and the music and this freaking little
fly
if i suddenly clap my hands in front of
my face it's because i'm trying to kill
this thing
it is bugging me uh which buffy angel
character would win glory or jasmine
i mean assuming glory is immune to
jasmine's head jumbo then glory would
win
pretty easily um
and i go on little rants and i lose
track of the
chat i i keep saying i'm going to give
up trying to scroll back and catch up
and i always do it one of these days i
am going to stop trying to do that and
just keep moving forward
what's your favorite sci-fi movie ever i
mean i it's probably ghostbusters which
is my favorite movie
of all time period anyways and happens
to have a lot of sci-fi
elements anyways bring it on turn 20
today what are your thoughts
i
there that's my thoughts is it wrong
that a part of me wants the snyder cut
to be really bad
i won't stop people praising it though i
don't want it to be bad
i actually very very rarely ever
want something to be bad i do think the
odds are in favor of it being bad though
and it won't matter because yes you're
right there is a
very loud portion of the audience who
will praise it no matter what it is
i wish someone would roast me on a stick
the way
council of geeks roasted sean connery
that was a light
that was a light searing it had best
that was not a roast
these weaklings get hangovers do you
have any advice on how to ask a girl out
on a date
ask her hey would you like to go on a
date sometime
you're asking someone who hasn't dated
like who hasn't had to ask or
has not been asked to go on a date
in oh my god
probably 26 years
no more than that yeah 26 27 years
i'm not someone to ask for dating advice
i'm really not
uh the tobias agency fired a female
assistant for transphobic tweets and now
a lot of people are accusing them of
misogyny and standing with the woman for
stating sexist
oh for god's sake
here's what i really really and i'm
it is so hard for me not to swear right
now
this is what i really hate about the sex
is real
thing it is such
it and i know that this alone is
me saying this is going to be something
that gets me dismissed by some people
it is a dog whistle and it is a strong
man at the same time
because it is something that transphobes
say to basically signal
yes i am not okay with trans people
but it is a statement that people who
are not invested
in the transgender
considerations of the world at all will
go well yeah
sex is real i guess i'm with them but
the thing is
nobody on the other side is saying that
biological sex doesn't exist
so the very argument sex is real yes no
[ __ ] nobody said it wasn't
oh god that
pisses me i'm not mad at you rowan i'm
not even mad at you for bringing
it up just the fact that that statement
has become the backbone
of coded transphobic language
just pisses me off so much because it
paints
transgender people as if we are saying
biological sex doesn't exist and i don't
know a single trans person who says that
okay i'm all right
uh what are your thoughts on the
aristocats i have no thoughts aside from
the fact that
um the burlesque troupe that i am
sometimes involved in did a group number
to the song everybody wants to be a cat
and it was great
uh the movie itself is really
really dumb
what does your cup say it says gender is
imaginary
which is not the same as saying sex is
not real so don't
don't and it's not actually something
that i firmly believe but this is cute
and has a unicorn on it so bite me
okay um
do you consider yourself a fan of paul
simon and art garfunkel i mean
when they work together sure i did
where oh carolyn you are cheeky
uh there's quite an old film now made in
my area
bradford in england it's called rita sue
and bob two
it's about a married man having an
affair with two teenage girls oh
that's gross uh it might it might even
be a good movie
but you know just my immediate gut
reaction to that is ah
thank you very much um ikari kid i
appreciate that
so i got my girlfriend into doctor who
started her on season one of new who and
she loves it that's great
i've gotten her indoctrinating she cried
when nine regenerated oh
what are your thoughts on clueless and
legally blonde of the two i definitely
prefer legally blonde
because l woods is you know
a demonstrably intelligent person
and she basically can do whatever she
wants
and she proves that over the course of
this thing it's just a matter of what
she puts her mind to and i enjoy her as
a character
more than the characters in clueless
favorite movie in a genre you don't
usually get into
um well love actually is my favorite
romantic comedy and i don't usually like
romantic comedy so there you go uh do
you think that tens end was
universal karma for john smith's death
sacrifice
uh death and sacrifice in the family of
blood um
i mean if you want a head cannon that
sure
do i think that no because there wasn't
anything thematically within it that
called to that as a possibility so that
would be strictly head canon
i think gloria's too full of herself to
have jasmine's powers work on her
that tracks uh it was brought to my
attention that michael crawford
was offered the eighth doctor before
poem again do you think he would have
been a good doctor
no dear god no
sweeney todd a rocky horror picture show
um
well since you said picture show i'm
assuming you mean movie version
because that is rocky horror now if you
mean stage version
which would just be rocky horror show
that for the stage i would prefer
sweeney todd
uh do you think we could get
oversaturated with the 10th doctor soon
time lower victoria out of time big
finish comics with 13. i suppose it
depends on what you actually buy inside
yes exactly that that is what i was
about to say
um because
he's not being shoved into the show
which is what most
people watch and all the other stuff
you're only going to be oversaturated
if you go out of your way to get it and
buy it
so i i would kind of say if you're
feeling
10th doctor overload you did it to
yourself
like with a certain amount of compassion
for people who are
compulsive completist uh completionists
like anyone who's like that who kind of
can't help themselves like
that's rough anyways but aside from that
like
if you feel you like you've got too much
10th doctor in your life that's
on you i believe you're not crazy about
movie theaters but any movies you saw
theatrically where you really enjoyed
the
experience of watching it in a theater
i'm not sure
well first of all thank you very much um
give me skittles now
i appreciate that a lot um
i don't know where i gave the impression
that i don't that i'm not crazy about
movie theaters i actually
really like my local movie theater and
especially
now in the time of covid i've come to
really appreciate how much i like going
to the theater
and uh how much i miss it
but i as as far as theatrical
experiences i
i've enjoyed most of the times i've gone
to the movies i mean some
things that really jump out in my head i
remember really enjoying going to the
theater to see the new king kong
because that that was a movie like it's
a flawed movie but
when i sat down to watch it it was like
i was seven years old again and it was
great
i saw jaws uh in the theater like as a
classics
you know presentation when i lived in
boston that was really
really cool to see and honestly avatar
was a really good theater going
experience i know like everyone likes to
crap all over that movie now but
it was a legitimately really cool
experience to go and see
let's see i have a friend who oh
there it goes again i need to give up
trying to keep up
but i do it anyway i cannot help it i
have a friend who met christopher
reichelstein when she was four
apparently she called him the c
word to his face wow
okay
hope they cut out the racial chinese
moment from the everyone
wants to be a cat number yes uh they did
re-edit that as i recall
um and actually it was it wasn't
it wasn't a version of everybody wants
to be from the movie it was a
cover of it and the cover had left that
bit out
um also just an idea can you please put
your videos on spotify
for a podcast
i i had never considered doing that
the thing is i i don't have the
bandwidth on my rss feed
to hold an audio version of the videos
that i make
um and it would it would cost me to do
that
um and i cannot imagine that the replays
i would get on spotify would even come
close to offsetting that
so i don't i don't think that'll ever
happen
uh rita sue and bob was the classic
british made for television film it's a
great comedy oh
yes of course uh adults romancing
children
barrel of laughs love it i i'm obviously
i haven't seen it so like if you like it
i'm not trying to knock you but like
that's
literally the only thing i know about it
what are your thoughts on mean girls
it's good movie
stop trying to make fetch happen it's
never going to happen
fun fact the silorians reemerged this
year
um i've only got the final episode of
season four
and the season five of angel left
looking forward to watching your videos
on it season five
of angels amazing it's absolutely
fantastic
been binging season five of lucifer good
good i
i'm glad other people like lucifer good
for you best regeneration story as of
now for me it's night of the doctor
caves of andrew zani
um if you're gonna count
night of the doctor i'd probably go with
that one
otherwise
see like i'm really overdue for a
re-watch on caves of andrew zhani
um not that i disliked the last time i
saw it but it's just been so long
and then i guess maybe the other one in
contention
um no
no i think you just need to leave it at
night of the doctor
which doctor has the best regeneration
my favorite is ecosystem it's fantastic
well the best regeneration or the best
regeneration episode because i make a
distinction
because like i love 11's regeneration
into 12. i don't like
time of the doctor though oh you of
course it flies in front of my face as
soon as i have something in my hand and
i can't
i can't clap at it
did you ever have an opinion of the
pollyanna movie not being sent in
vermont no because i have absolutely no
stake in pollyanna
so no
i literally never had an opinion on that
but uh thank you again
for the super chat i really appreciate
that
uh i like the matt smith version of the
doctor
a lot of people do what are your
thoughts on the rescuers of the rescuers
down under i prefer rescuers down under
immensely uh the first rescuers
is just not really my jam
regenerations didn't used to be uniform
transition each one was different
yes but there was also at a time when
not as many people cared about
continuity so they just kind of
did whatever i think my favorite movie
theater experience is still return of
the king ooh
that's cool have you heard of curse
started watching it on netflix
got a nasty surprise when i saw frank
miller's name on the title sequence um
i've seen it like shoved in my face by
netflix i know nothing about it and
haven't watched it
not going to be here long just wondering
are you doing youtube full-time
yes by default um
so all right here's where things are
right now i have unemployment coming in
um the job market around here is very
limited i am
i'm hoping that through
growth on the channel and or the patreon
um
and hopefully also um getting
you know the the book out there and see
what that brings in that
i will be in a position where i'm able
to cover all my bills and taxes that's
the thing right now
is what i bring in per month between
youtube and
patreon actually covers my bills my
standard expenses
you know things like uh payment on the
car
and uh you know electricity water
food all that is covered with that stuff
but it there isn't enough leftover for
me to set aside to go in my taxes
come the end of the year so that's where
i'm like i'm needing to build up a
little more but
yes i am now doing youtube full-time i'm
just hesitant to word it that way
because it makes it sound like my bills
are currently all covered and
they're not yet i'm i'm trying to get
there
um i've gotta i've got a decent shot at
it um i really do
like if i can if i can get my car
paid off within the next year which
will be hard i'll have to concentrate
some high payments into it
but if i can do that and have that
expense be gone i might be okay
do you think a puppet show can be made
for an adult without beating without
being adolescent
it could it would be very hard to
sell though uh do you rap oh dear god no
[Laughter]
oh no no no no thoughts on bridesmaids
sought once never deemed to see it again
you want to know what's a barrel of
laughs
it was my parents who showed me rita sue
and bob too
you know what my mother was the one who
introduced me to the rocky horror
picture show so
i ain't judging what are your thoughts
on the boys
it is a show that i don't watch
uh on partners jumping into who mine did
unexpectedly the other week but decided
to jump in at
season nine she jumped out again going
freaky
yeah that's an odd one to jump in on
like there are ones aside from series
one that
work as jump on points series 5 works
series 10 works
series 11 probably works um i'm hesitant
to recommend that one because
i don't like it especially but that's
personal taste
series nine though yeah that's a that's
a weird one to jump in on
uh on the topic of regenerations what
regeneration
looks the best like the special effects
honestly
i like the instantaneousness of
11 into 12. i like that it was just snap
and there he is
especially because we were expecting you
know the really big overblown
uh the stuff that god they really went
over the top lieutenant
and i loved that it was just boom
uh i know i'm biased because she's one
of my favorite characters but i think
drew cella is the best big bad
in buffy i don't think you get to call
her a big bad she was never a seasoned
big bag she's a recurring baddie sure
i don't think she gets to earn the title
big bad though i think you've misapplied
that
uh purely because she's the only one who
remains at large at the end
uh i really hope that the extra playing
the clown
who puts his hand over his mouth after
the doctor called captain
hook a total bore got paid extra for
that
so what rowan's referring to there is my
review for
the classic doctor who serial the
greatest show in the galaxy is up in the
break room of geeks
and uh that yes that is a moment from
that my favorite movie going experience
was seeing fantasia in the cinema five
years ago
there were a number of disney films i
got to see in the cinema again like when
i was younger
um i saw fantasia i saw
101 dalmatians peter pan
i actually saw a song on the south
back before they decided to start
pretending that it didn't exist
uh what are your thoughts on disney's
robin hood um
it's fun created a ton of furries
i am sure uh have you watched heather's
either the show or the film
nope uh what made it worse that the
opening titles looked cool
so i thought hey it looks kind of like
something from sin city and then the
name dropped it i went oh
[ __ ] success is within your grasp oh
thank you carowind
uh have any interesting stories about
any of the figures on this shelf
not really they're almost all gifts
like that's it like someone gave me this
someone gave me that or i bought it for
myself
like there isn't really a story to most
of these ever heard of mongrels a puppet
show for grown-ups about stray animals
i have not have you seen doom patrol
nope i don't have hbo max
i'm almost caught up i keep doing this
to myself i saw return of the king in
theaters with a friend i made him sit
on uh the side of me that would keep him
from crossing in front of me if he
needed to get up
very smart i refused to miss a single
second because i knew
the books uh are was mentally comparing
them
he called me lame oh whatever
what are your thoughts on oliver and
company some good songs
it's kind of fun i like it more as a kid
have you ever seen the bbc version of
robin hood no i have not
thoughts on gotham knights and goth
gossam
gotham knights and suicide squad killed
the justice league
they are video games that i will never
play and i definitely don't have
thoughts on killed justice league
because
it was a completely pre-rendered trailer
which tells you absolutely nothing about
gameplay whatsoever
like a little more credit to gotham
knights they had some stuff that looked
like gameplay
footage as well but like the suicide
squad killed the justice league
it was a fun trailer but it tells you
nothing about the game
what about tim alien give him a scritch
for me okay yeah all right carowinds got
me there
he's out of shot but my dragon who's
right up here
ah he doesn't really have
a story either
but i uh
i do love this guy so yes as
carowinds said his name is tamaleon
oh okay all right i i woke him up i'm
sorry buddy
yeah it's okay no you don't have to give
me that look
yes no you it's just people it's all
right
okay he's being fidgety okay all right
all right all right
hang on
there you go bud
okay he gets uppity it's okay
uh so actually i'm gonna pop right quick
i had a few questions from the discord
and i'm gonna feel one of those
i had one somebody just went
hallelujah at me and i think he was i
think they were uh
um no it no it is a he oh put it in his
in his name yeah i think he was just
baiting me because that was my big
issue on the snyder cut thing although i
i do wanna i do wanna amend something
with my criticism of the use of
hallelujah for the snyder cut trailer
um somebody said in the comments and
then upon request did provide me a
source on this
that the reason or at least part of the
reason that hallelujah is in that
trailer is
it was um zack snyder's daughter's
favorite song so to recap in case you
don't remember
the major reason why snyder had to leave
that film was his daughter committed
suicide
and so he was obviously going through a
lot
and apparent and that was the song
apparently they played at her funeral
she loved it very much so
i'm not at this point i'm not as harsh
on zack snyder himself for wanting to
use the song
i do still think it was a failure of the
higher ups in the marketing department
for not going uh
zach look we get it i think it'd be
great if you use the song in the film
but if you use it in the marketing
material the optics of it are going to
be
really bad for anyone who doesn't know
what you're doing and most people aren't
going to know what you're doing
so i still say somebody screwed up
i'm now saying it wasn't in this because
i get why he did it
but like somebody should have stopped
him
uh there was captain scarlet that was a
puppet show made for kids it was very
dark and could be enjoyed by adults
yeah i never watched um the
oh god what's his name the anderson
the guy who did stuff like that um
my really my only familiarity with it is
through a friend of mine
a podcaster um
who he uh he has a pot well he has a
number of
of podcasts and uh one of them is the
palace of glittering delights where he
talks about lots of stuff he talks about
um spiderman and comics and tv
shows that he grew up watching and uh
jerry anderson there we go
and he and so like i know captain
scarlet because he talked about that but
it's not something i've uh i've ever
seen excuse me
andy leyland is the name of that
podcaster by the way
and it was the uh the palace of
glittering delights
my embroidery is still on your shelf yes
of course amanda i love that
i absolutely love it
uh incorporating conan into marvel
comics as has now happened good idea bad
idea it depends on how they did it
like that's that's an idea that is 100
execution dependent
um there's an interesting sounding
documentary
series on shutter about cursed films the
final episode is about the twilight zone
movie helicopter accident oh
which peter pan do you prefer the one
from 1953 made by disney or the one from
2003 made by universal am i allowed to
say neither
sorry what are your thoughts on peter
cavalli is the thinker and the new
suicide
suicide squad movie i want to see what
he does with it
and i hope he survives in the movie for
a while but i i'm not going to depend on
that
have you heard of in the flesh uh show
about zombies medicated to regain
consciousness and is an incredibly
beautiful but depressing gem that i
definitely recommend
i have heard of it i have deliberately
not watched it because its core pitch
is too similar to an idea that i have
and i want to like
i want to execute on that idea myself
and not have it overly influenced by
other things that
had uh similar core premises either by
repeating what
they did and being influenced by it or
by changing what i want to do because i
want it to be less like something that
already existed
in the uk theaters uh and critics seem
to be hanging a lot on tenant calling it
the most important film of nolan's
career is that shared in the u.s
um first of all thank you very much for
the super chat um
i don't know like there's a lot of undue
pressure on the film just because it's
part of
the first wave of films that are
supposed to get people back into
theaters again
so it's become a film that's bigger than
what it actually is
i have not read reviews and i am
actually not
going to so as far as
any kind of critical consensus in the
u.s i don't know because i
am avoiding it so apparently there's
going to be an animated version of the
long halloween comic
now i like the long halloween actually
quite a bit
but like i've not been enjoying the
animated um dc things
that are adapting specific things
they've been decent to awful
he's adorable where can i get one oh
tamaleon um i got him at a renaissance
fair about 20 years ago
um from a vendor who i never saw again
um you can find stuff like him like on
etsy
if you dig around
let's see personally i hated the
justice league trailer as i hate the
fact that we only have those four
characters and it's a continuation
of the arkhamverse and the justice
league are
evil i mean like it's a video game it
seems odd to me
to get worked up
about the um about how it affects
continuity of anything
because it doesn't have to be in
continuity of anything like i figure if
there's one medium where you're allowed
to go off the rails
and do your own thing completely it's a
video game
because it's it's disconnected from
everything
alistair sim in the classic saint
trinius films played
by both brother and sister millicent
fritten slash
clarence fritton okay
i okay
[Laughter]
one of the characters in my show i named
after georgette from oliver and company
purely because the actor i have player
reminds me a lot of the character from
the film
oh [ __ ] this freaking fly
um
i lost track of where i was now it's a
shame that your patreon pledge for movie
reviews commissions are sold out because
i was hoping one day i could get you to
review the
movie ordinary people um
i hope damn thing
um i have on occasion
taken um commissions outside of that
structure through
paypal i mean the one thing i would say
and like this
this is a reason if i ever get caught up
i might open it up to more than five
slots
but i need to get caught up first so
like if you want to go outside that and
commission me through
paypal you can do that just know it's
gonna be a while till i get to it
is all
see my sister really wants a dragon like
that for her steampunk outfit
i'll show her you wearing it later she's
gonna flip
nice very nice do you prefer hand
puppets or marionettes hand puppets
they're
way more expressive what's your least
favorite tim burton movie
that's a good question um
honestly probably batman returns
i keep giving it another shot thinking
maybe i'll find something that
works this time and it just never
happens
finding neverland was better i'll take
your word for that decided to watch a dc
anime movie for the first time went with
mask of the fantasm
very good call i like how the joker was
used not the main focus but still
important yes
i mean that that movie is so good for so
many reasons use of the joker is one of
them
just purchase mrs miss misses
missy series one this is essentially my
entrance to big finish really excited to
listen to it
uh your review of it was was informative
nice i hope you enjoy i had a lot of fun
with that
hang on you don't put on hallelujah to
get in the right mood
i learned so much from your vids yeah i
i would not
advise doing that um
especially not the leonard cohen version
like i know he originated the thing but
yeah okay so i'm gonna
field another question that came in from
the discord
uh this was ask my favorite disney
animation studios era
i.e the golden age the renaissance the
revival etc
um now i went back and forth between the
disney renaissance and
what i would consider to be the more
recent stretch
i guess you would call it disney revival
i'm i'm inclined to say disney revival
and
here's why the disney renaissance at
least as far as
genuinely good movies went from 1989 to
1994 so it went five
years and five films little mermaid
rescuers down under beauty and the beast
aladdin lion king
very solid run uh even though rescuers
down under is often forgotten
in that mix uh the revival era
probably technically kicked off with
princess and the frog but i would
consider the really strong run to have
come
from starting with tangled so that's
tangled frozen wreck-it ralph
big hero 6 zootopia moana that's six
films and from 2010 to 2016
so it's more films and ran longer and
also i think has a better chance at not
being over because
i mean the last few films we got from
disney have been sequels that i didn't
much care for the wreck-it ralph sequel
and the frozen sequel but once we get
off sequels maybe they'll pick it up
again whereas after lion king like
things went
for disney and you'll notice pixar was
not on there i do not count pixar when
i'm counting disney stuff
everyone else does i do not i am very
stubborn like that
let's see i just found my favorite
version of a tardis team seven and ace
have the same birthday
talk about destiny to be together oh wow
i did not know that
do you think mark hamill would make a
good live-action joker i think he would
have
probably up until about 10 years ago i'm
not sure
he's got the physicality to do it
anymore i mean it's part of the reason
he doesn't even do the voice work
anymore because he gets so physically
into it and he's just at an age where
that's taxing for him
the most annoying thing about fandom was
there have been no confirmation
regarding amber heard in aquaman 2.
like i
i mean this might sound weird coming
from me
but i like honestly i'm
i don't care i think part of it is
because we're
like i don't know i don't i don't have a
way to quantify this
but
here's part of what irritates me about
the backlash against amber heard
i feel like it's inherently harsher
because she's a woman and i mean that
twofold
and i and this is not me accusing you
rowan or anyone else specifically i'm
talking about the overall phenomenon
and this is not me saying like you
shouldn't be
frustrated or skeptical of her side of
the story or what we've learned
since and first of all that's the first
thing i need to cop to there's only so
much
looking into what i did which is not a
ton so that that that's the first thing
and then uh in addition to that
i feel like part of the backlash is
now
people who are very unpleasant
have someone that they can point to and
go see sometimes
men get falsely accused and i hate that
but i don't have it in me to turn that
anger against
herd herself i am going to keep that
anger
with the people who are thinking that
they can dismiss all women
who bring accusations because of one
woman who
may have falsified it and i know that
there are people more on the side who
agree with me who are also directing
their anger at her and i'm like no
that's misdirected you should be
running interference and
being sure that this is not allowed to
be something that they get to keep
pointing to
so while i'm not saying that we should
just like pretend nothing happened and
move forward as if
there's nothing wrong because i don't
believe that but
every time i see the question brought up
i just kind of do a heavy sigh
because the whole situation just makes
me very very very tired
what are your thoughts on atlantis the
lost empire looks great not that
good uh any new movie mashups love that
video i love that video too
uh but no i haven't had any new ideas
for it
it's it's just been you know
just hasn't panned out that much
have you ever seen the british sitcom
vicious
i have not if not it's about an elderly
gay couple oh
i've seen clips of it i've seen clips of
it of derek jacobian and mckellen i
haven't seen proper episodes
i'm just sick of superman sick of evil
superman especially since batman is
rumored to be in the game yeah
like evil superman's overdone totally
agree with that
have you seen awkward puppets no tim
burns planet of the apes is his worst oh
god yeah you know i
actually tend to forget that that's a
thing that happened
why did you remind me
is it istanbul not constantinople
um let's see who's your favorite
character from hamilton
um
i mean the most fun is probably
lafayette
i think i find um
either burr
or angelica to be the most interesting
are there any good horrors you'd
recommend it really depends on what
your personal stripe of horror is
best judy whitaker performance dr beth
latimer or beverly from st training well
i
i don't know saint trainees this is the
second time this thing's been brought up
i don't know saint drainians
at all um and beth latimer i'm assuming
that was her character in
broad church um
i mean i think that performance
struck me harder than her doctor at
least so far
yeah my if my friends ever find out why
her character is called george
she may hit me um and she may be right
too
anthony ainley also has the same
birthday as sylvester and sophie all
right wow
i really piled up there what are your
thoughts on disney's the black cauldron
boy that movie didn't work
some interesting visuals but boy oh boy
did it not work
one of the all-time worst sidekicks ever
i hate gergie i hate him
i hate that he died and they brought him
back let him stay dead why did they
bring him ah
kill him
ah okay
fantasia or friend taser2000 how is that
even a question
fantasia jeez you're trapped in the last
movie you've washed with the last person
you texted
how screwed are you i suppose it depends
on the situation that we're trapped in
um
the last person i texted would be my
partner liz and last movie i watched was
the
documentary howard on disney plus so i
think i'm okay
i'm in musical theater land with my
partner i'll live
now that i'm getting into the series
itself i'd say my least favorite
burton uh film is dark shadows see i
never got around to even seeing that one
so
uh did you get a chance to read the
guardian article
uh dang hang on uh about russell t
davies calling out disney plus for a
lack of lgbtq plus representation i did
not
so no opinion haven't read it st
trainings is about girls at a boarding
school the sequel is david tennant like
i know that as a piece of trivia but i
still haven't seen it
and don't intend to i wonder how much
the bill would come to of someone
commissioning you
to do individual overdue reviews for
every episode of friends
[Music]
um how many seasons of friends were
there
it's gonna run you multiple thousands of
dollars to get me to do that
uh taryn is a way worse character than
man gergie
disagree because i don't remember who
taryn even was
i remember gergie though
st trainings was my favorite film when i
was little and it doesn't surprise me at
all considering
i'm a super gay girl cheers
gertie in the books was said to be a
much better character and kind of a
badass it wouldn't be hard to be a much
better character
do you watch family guy not anymore i
just kind of fell off it
thank you very much uh angas
i feel like i pronounced it right at
some point and i didn't just now
i don't know um this could be video
essay but why did mcu
work out while dc eu and universal dart
and universal dark universe etc haven't
because everyone else tried to jump to
the end
that's why i mean the the dc eu
failed because it's second film tried to
be the team up movie
the dark universe failed because its
first film wasn't a film it was a setup
for future movies
the reason the mcu worked and the reason
anything like this works
is you get people who caring about the
characters first
and then you start to bring them
together you can't bring a bunch of
characters people don't give a damn
about together and expect them to do
anything just because
oh look they're all in one movie yeah
but i don't like them or i don't know
who
know who they are or don't like your
version of them
you know the the mcu did the leg work
to put out iron man thor
incredible hulk captain america before
they teamed everybody up for the first
time
so that people came to see avengers
because they
already liked at least some of these
characters if not all of them
everyone else tried to skip ahead to
basically make their own avengers
they tried to skip steps they didn't do
the work
i'm not sure i can get a video essay out
of that because it's really that
straightforward
did you consider watching love craft
country i actually would really like to
see lovecraft country liz has started
watching it she likes it but i don't
have hbo max
i can't see it
uh would you rather be a member of the
scooby gang or angel incorporated
um i'm inclined to say scooby gang just
because i feel like
my fate there will be less horrific even
if i die it's gonna be quicker
less torture involved the sequel
involves the search for pirate treasure
boy if that isn't the default
storyline like oh we what do we do uh
pirate treasure
uh i never actually knew that russell g
davis mark gates and derek jacoby were
all gay i'm not judging i was just
surprised
okay uh here with your bi-weekly
reminder that one day you should watch
doctor in distress
oh i will
i will do you work out
um i run um
but that's something i've only taken up
recently but otherwise no
no i don't i should i should more than i
do but
i'm just happy with myself that i've
been consistent about the running
uh 10 seasons of friends but i
personally usually skip the last three
okay so if someone wanted to pay me to
review
all of the seasons of friends that will
probably run you six grand
that's not a firm number for me that's
like i think
if i'd if i ran my math right
not tracy
not a question but i highly recommend
something wicked this way comes from
1983
dark fantasy horror from disney i um
i kind of add that in my watch list
because i'm pretty sure it's on disney
plus
i have been meaning to see that because
i read the book um
i've seen some of the illustration of
the books and
gurkey is a lot taller too i feel that
annoying sidekick version was something
disney came up with oh i don't doubt
that he's dignified
i still hate him i didn't like friends
because it felt uh
because i felt it was too whitewashed
and there was too much tokenism
that's probably a criticism i would have
rewatching it now
the bits that i saw when i was younger i
never watched it regularly
i didn't have enough awareness for that
to bug me at the time
probably would irritate me more now
uh black cauldron is one that i would
actually accept a live action remake of
the one request
i have is to keep john hurt's voice as
the horn king no one else says pig like
him
like black cauldron in general i have no
problem with them remaking because it
didn't work
like that's what i think more remakes
should be more remakes should be
of things that didn't quite work but of
course they don't do that they remake
classics which is a
flawed premise in the first place it
almost never works out
when you pitch a movie today you i have
this idea for a film producer oh
interesting does it build up to a
cinematic universe you what
no well well there's the door then
good water
uh what are your thoughts on rodgers and
hammerstein important but also not to my
taste
uh
let's see i've been looking into comic
sales statistics and it seems trades and
graphic novels are what's keeping the
comics industry of float while digital
comics
still have a long way although they
haven't done a very good job at pushing
digital comics and they also
to my memory like i've never gotten into
digital comics to my
understanding is they've also kind of
failed to do
the basic thing that you should do with
digital distribution which is to make it
cheaper than the physical version
my understanding is they either didn't
do that or didn't do it
um you know when they started
or did it by such a minor increment that
it basically was the same price
and that was a big mistake
um did you ever watch the dnc in your
underwear with a closed peg on each
nipple
no comment pirate it then i don't like
pirating i don't i just don't like doing
it
found a brown pinstripe soup that worked
soup
suit that works so well for tenant at
goodwill for 10 bucks
wow and it fits absolute score
oh did i get you oh i didn't get them
i have the other elements but i haven't
had a suit for a while
excuse me that is awesome john i hope
that pulls together for you
i am going to wrap this up fairly soon
quick fairly soon quick
i need more water have you seen the
netflix show i'm not okay with this
they use covet as an excuse to cancel it
nope uh you don't have hbo max liz your
loving partner does and there's stuff
there you want to watch what a dilemma
no she doesn't have hbo max
she has hbo the channel
which means she watches it when it airs
live
on sunday nights and every other sunday
i'm here
with my kid and then even sundays where
maybe i'm with her like i'm
on my way back home on sunday so that i
can start
working on this stuff in the book and
everything else on monday morning
because i'm still
i'm making myself put in a five um
a five day work week
monday through friday so yeah
if liz had hbo max that'd be different
she doesn't she just has hbo
pretty sure yahtzee crosstalk made a
joke about bury pirate treasure being
something of an
an executive yells over his shoulder on
the way to the cocaine tasting session
i think he's talking about executives
going to cocaine testing sessions i
believe that particular one was
the kind of thing a writer tosses over
their shoulder as they leave the office
that bang on the hour the bar
opens i might re-watch zero punctuation
when i'm
as background noise what are your
thoughts on grease don't
like it uh have never liked it
have you ever watched anything from
musical hell i don't think so
what are your thoughts on game of
thrones last season sucked
what would you say is your earliest fan
shock or betrayal moment mine was when
mission impossible film turned the hero
the tv series jim phelps into the
villain um
off the top of my head i don't know i'd
have to think about that
i'm annoyed with my imagination because
i don't like the ronnie yet
i accidentally thought of a story that
would fit her and it's actually one of
my better ideas
hey look if you can turn around and make
her actually works as a character go for
it
how would you rank the six james bonds
dalton's my favorite more is my least
the problem is
i haven't seen uh the dalton films and i
didn't see the one with george ladies
and be so i actually can't rank all of
them
sorry do you like the spice girls not
particularly
i have a certain nostalgia for some of
their 90s stuff just because it was on
the radio when i was a teenager but
that's about it
because i'm old i just remember one of
my characters wears a burgundy coat
similar to yours
um so
if you do watch it just remember you
copied me
the only good thing about this about a
six pirate movie is that hypocrite
nightly won't be in it
did i miss something something happened
with karen knightley that i'm unaware of
and i'm gonna really regret asking i'm
curious about your writing process and
how to
um get out of being in writer's block
the reason i ask is because i'm trying
to get back
in my groove making web comics oh
like webcomic format i'm not sure that i
would be
good to help with because that's the
kind of format
that i i think i could do
so like the reason i finished a book and
why i think i can finish
additional ones once this one's out is i
know how it ends i know
so i know where i'm going me personally
i can only write if i know the
destination
i cannot do the thing where i work oh
i'll just do this but see where it goes
and see where it goes see where it go
that's how i end up being like i don't
know where this is going and then my
brain won't focus
um so that's like the major thing for me
i have to know where i'm going
no matter how long it is even when i
write short even when i write like
10-minute plays i need to know the
ending before i can get
anywhere on the topic of musicals
thoughts on sweeney taught i really want
to play that part
um that's my thought
uh one of my friends is actually making
a doctor who fan film and he wants me to
play the doctor oh
lucky i have a friend who has yet to
watch chippenhall's torchwood stuff i'm
going to try and find
uh the headset from clockwork orange
that peels your eyes open
not all of his stuff is that bad sorry
about the typos don't sweat it
uh gotta wrap it up soon um i just
remembered from your
star trek below decks review you like
archer i do
i'm not current with it anymore um this
is one of those things that
i just hadn't put the effort in to catch
up on
is there a particular genre you
gravitate toward mores than others
personally it's period drama
sci-fi and fantasy broadly speaking
thank you miss wicked wolf so yes i did
actually catch up on the chat oh i
caught up and then you dropped another
one my writing process is literally a
bottle of
disarono and a sitcom in the background
for white noise hey we've all got
different processes
okay i've had a story buzzing in my head
for like seven years now i can't decide
if i want to make it a book or a graphic
novel so i keep putting it off
like the book that my kickstarter is
launching for in two weeks
um i started writing that
six no 18 years ago i started writing
that
so you know seven years you're rookie
what are your thoughts on on nerd erotic
i don't watch it
that is my thought uh
was a pleasant i keep trying to i keep
trying to sign off
you people are trying to keep me here it
was a pleasant surprise to see uh jody
may as the witch
in the young seriously flashback in game
of thrones season five such an
underrated
actress love her since last of the
mohicans oh i didn't recognize her at
all
all right i'm putting my hand over the
over the chat screen so that i cannot
see it
and and i am wrapping up for the day
thank you so much for joining me um i
hope everyone has a great rest of the
week
the next live stream will basically be a
launch party for the kickstarter because
the kickstarter will go live the same
day
so tune in in two weeks for that
excuse me
i'm so ladylike hope everybody has a
great night
um i wish you only the best and
please remember that you are beautiful
you are valid you are loved you are the
council
i just run the meetings and drink the
water
and until next time this council is
adjourned
have a good night